a recently discovered species of frog
fish has been dubbed the psychedelic
fish because of the swirl of beige and
peach zebra stripes that run from its
blue eyes to its tail histy of fry any
psychedelic a' is also unique because of
the way it hops along the bottom of the
sea floor using its lower fins the
psychedelic fish expels water from tiny
gill openings to jet itself forward
their awkward motion might be attributed
to a tail that's curl to one side
limiting their ability to steer
themselves even when stationary the fish
seems to use its lower fins like feet to
position itself dive operators in the
waters off on bond island in Indonesia
noticed the colorful fish in early 2008
and scientists at the University of
Washington conducted DNA research to
confirm it was a new species and part of
the order of angler fishes psychedelic
a' has a gelatinous body covered with
thick folds of skin that protected from
sharp edged corals it has a knack for
pushing its way into coral crevices for
hiding it has forward-looking eyes like
humans and it's about the size of a
human fist the fish is shy and secretive
usually seeking a new hiding place
within 10 to 15 minutes of discovery by
divers that probably accounts for why
the species has remained hidden until
now researchers say while other frog
fish and similar species are known to
jettison themselves before they take off
swimming none of these species have been
seen hopping like the psychedelic fish
[Music]